الماسك متهم بالتناقض ونازله ضده انتقادات
كبيره والسبب حريه التعبير وموقفه منها
فمن اول ما اشترى ماسك تويتر قال انه راح
تكون المنصه المفضله لحريه التعبير وقال
انه راح يعزز من قدره مستخدمي تويتر على
التعبير بحريه وقالوا انه تويتر مو ممكن
يستجيب للحكومات في طلبات الرقابه الا لو
رفعوا عليهم المسدسات لا وكمان وصف نفسه
بالدعم لحريه التعبير المطلقه لكن اليوم
يبدو الوضع تغير والشواهد كثيره اولها
احصائيات من كم يوم نشرتها صحيفه اسبانيه
قالت انه تويتر استجاب ل 83% من طلبات
الرقابه
لحكومات استبداديه مثل ما وصفتها الصحيفه
طيب ايش يعني هذا الكلام يعني تويتر
استجاب لطلبات حكومات بحذف تغريدات ومحتوى
مو عاجبها او بيتعارض مع قوانينها
وسياستها واحداثها كان حذف عدد من
الحسابات اللي بتتعارض مع الرئيس التركي
طيب اردوغان قبل يومين من الانتخابات بناء
على طلب الحكومه التركيه وفي امثله ثانيه
اعطتها الصحيفه من الهند كمان وهذا
التقرير طبعا حط ايلون ماسك في مرمى
الانتقادات لكن الشاهد يعني الادهى والامر
على تغير موقف ماسك هو كلام طلع منه هو
شخصيا فالشهر الماضي ماسك كان طلع في
مقابل على بي بي سي وانسال لو تويتر حذف
فيلم وثائقي عن رئيس الوزراء الهندي من
تويتر ماسك رد وقال انه مو متاكد ايش صار
في هذا الفيلم تحديدا لكن عموما الهند
قوانينها صارمه جدا بخصوص ما يعرض على
المنصات وقال انه لما ينحط في موقف بينفذ
القوانين وبيحذف المواد وبينفذ الرقابه او
ينسجنوا موظفينه فاكيد راح يستجيب لي
الرقابه او انه ما عنده خيار ولما طلعت من
كم يوم الدراسه اللي تكلمنا عنها في
البدايه يعني في صحفي في اعاد نشرها
ومعاها علق بجمله ماسك الشهيره الس ابقه
انا مع حريه التعبير المطلقه ماسك هنا رد
على الصحفي وقال له انت غبي وريني فين كان
عندنا خيار نعمل شيء تاني وما عملنا